what happens when you press a key on the
keyboard so fine sitting at word or
something and I type in something like
hello computer file what actually
happens between me hitting the H of the
keyboard and the computer displaying the
age on screen so we're looking at how
does the actual key price go from me
physically pressing the key to a
computer painting the letter on the
screen and the same applies whether
we're typing into a word processor or
whether we're playing a game or anything
that is requiring user input there's a
chain which starts off with the hardware
where we have a key that we're pressing
that's my finger there and then we're
going to end up in the software with the
computer displaying the age on screen
how does actually and what's going on
between those two things I mean the
first place to start is is how does the
system actually work and in many ways
it's no different from your light switch
I mean what the switch is there is
you've effectively got an electrical
circuit and you've got a switch and when
we press the button on the thing we
close that circuit and then the current
can pass through and we can get an
electrical signal typically in a
computer system with the mid 80s for
example that'd be +5 volts these days
it's probably +4 e 2.3 it doesn't matter
there's a certain voltage which signals
at that key has been pressed how many
different possibilities are there from
the keyboard obviously you've got all
the keys and then you've got shift and
all the keys you've got Alton all the
key you know they're all sorts of
possibility how do you know how many
there are in total probably well I mean
what is it I think it's a PC 103
keyboard is the standards unless there's
a hundred keys on a keyboard roughly if
you think about you got 26 letters of
the alphabet 10 numbers numeric keypad
that's got another 116 or so on it all
the other keys I think you're looking
roughly when you can't function keys how
home clear page up page down shift left
shift right shift Control Alt Delete
theoretically there's probably two to
the hundred different possible
combinations of keys you compress from
none of them being pressed to all of
them being pressed and overcome
oceans in between that's actually really
good question because with like a
Raspberry Pi
we've got input pins um GPIO general
purpose input output like I said okay
let's build a keyboard we want a key
that's got the a key say well let's
connect that to an input so that when we
press it it makes that input we can then
read it great there's only about 16 or
so inputs on here you're gonna run out
of inputs so how do you actually handle
that you don't really want have to
connect a hundred different keys under
the keyboard which is where the first
interesting bit of our story sort of
comes along because the way that
keyboard actually lays things out so
let's take the screws off the back of
this yeah so because of the way these
things work you actually end up needing
to screw them down pretty tightly
otherwise you get for the case where
keys wouldn't actually make contact with
the keyboard
well how many screws was that quite a
few so you need to I mean let me get a
home you'll see why it's so Kylie held
down and that you've got all these
lovely little suction cup thingies that
sort of sit on top of the actual
mechanism so that when you press the key
these then get squashed on top of the
contacts like that so do all people to
it like this these days they do
sometimes I actually had physical micro
switches and things so the older they
are the better quality that I tend to be
made or things and there's different
mechanisms so you get those annoying IBM
model M that go click click click click
click click click I probably just
started a completely flame war I like my
keyboard soft and mushy in essence it
comes down to price and what you need
them for so this is a circuit board of a
keyboard from the 90s I imagine so
you've got some control things at the
back and then this is basically the
brains of the keyboard if we look at a
particular key like this one you can see
that you've got 2 bits of the circuit so
if you've got one of the things over the
rubber cut that actually when it gets
pressed down you'll see who sort of
squashes down and if you look underneath
you see there's a little black dot
that's just basically carbon and so when
such as they would probably carve it on
here again it completes the circuit so
if you actually look at how it's
connected up then you start to see some
interesting things so let's have a look
at this one it's got two contacts one of
them here one of them here and if we
follow this one we'll see that this is
also connected to the same the bottom
left side of this switch and the bottom
left side of that one and so on all the
way along we could follow this trace
until we get to the last one it actually
changed to the top-right for the last
couple and then it ends up going into
the chip here that controls things the
other side we can see just a similar
sort of thing there's a connection to
that one then it comes down as a link
and next to that one and so on so what's
actually going on here so the way to
think about this is that we have one set
of wires that run vertically I mean they
don't on the keyboard because it's a
physical side of things and they're just
running like that and then we have
another set that a running horizontally
across them so effectively you're
forming a grid now these don't connect
so there's no connection between the
blue wires and the red Y's except via
the switch so there's a switch at every
cross point yeah exactly this is a
switch there and of course when you
press that switch that does then connect
the red wire to the blue wire what
happens is if we apply no voltages
across it they're all connected to
ground then we'd read nothing across the
top of these or vice versa it doesn't
matter which way around you build it if
on the other hand we put a voltage on
the top wire if we then close that
switch we press that key your five volts
will be connected to the red wire and
would come out of this red wine so we'd
end up with +5 volts there because we've
completed the circuit through that
closed switch if we pressed it here then
we'd get +5 volts coming out here so
press both of them we see that let go
then
the voltages disappear so the advantage
of this is that we only need one wire
along there and we can then detect any
of these switches being pressed so if
you've got there we can work out one we
can read them so if we for example had
eight of these things we could then read
them and then read that answer the
computer has a bite any one of the bits
in
by it would tell us if any one of those
keys were press what we can then do is
put a voltage on the next one any of the
switches on here when we close them we
could then read out there and so the way
that we get around having so many keys
and not requiring a hundred inputs we've
this idea of a matrix all the keys are
laid out so this might be Q this might
be Double A that one's W is s the D and
so on and what the computer does when he
wants to read them is it cycles through
applying 5 volts to one line can then
read which keys are pressed on that line
puts five bolts on the next line can
then read what keys so it can read them
all in sequence same for all you end up
doing is reading first line the second
one the third line the fourth line
you only need eight inputs depending on
how many keys you are we said about 100
so you're gonna need about 1213
different lines so you cycle through
each of those lines reading in the eight
keys on each one and you start again and
you can find out what keys are pressed
you had to program that you had to read
for many things which is it's fine but
you're then writing software which is
constantly what we call polling the
polling the hardware to find out what's
being pressed and if you think about a
keyboard 99% of the time you're not
pressing any keys even if you're typing
fast you press a key and then as far as
the computers concern there's a long
period of time where you're not pressing
key before you press the next one and so
on so it's relatively inefficient from
the computers point of view so if you've
got something like the BBC micro they
started to develop slightly more
advanced keyboards which would scan it
and then only tell the computer to check
it when there was a key press so the
hardware and the BBC micro is scanning
through each of the lines several
hundred thousand times a second it's got
a one megahertz clock which is
sequencing through all the different
keys on things and if any one of them is
pressed it sends a thing interrupts the
computer and says you need to check what
keys pressed and looking keyboard at
which point the computer can then check
what keys pressed and handle it so you
can get some speed advantages doing that
when you get to things like the PC or an
Atari or an Amiga things get even more
interesting so we're still talking
harder at the moment because as we noted
on here these tracks which form these
wires here end up connecting to a chip
and generally on these sort of machines
these chips end up being small
microcontrollers so they're actually
small computers in their own right so
your keyboard is a computer in its own
right and what that is doing is running
one single program which is scanning the
keyboard and it's running a thing that
says okay you've pressed the key I'm
going to send a message over a serial
link to the computer to say this keys
been pressed and then when they let go
of it I sent another one so this keys
been released so actually on a PC on a
Atari or something you don't have to
check what keys are being pressed
because and so you do all the hardware
side of things yourself because actually
the hardware is intelligent enough in
fact on the Atari it was called the
intelligent keyboard to do all these
things itself and so you just get a
message coming down a specific serial
link saying okay there's a keep'em press
on the keyboard and it'll give you
what's called a scan code so you don't
get on most modern keyboards you
probably get an ASCII character code or
a Unicode character you did some people
some of the earlier keyboards were ASCII
keyboards you press keys and you get the
ASCII character code out of it these you
get what tends to be called a scan code
which is literally just the location of
where the key was scanned on things so
you might for example have Q being one W
maybe to a maybe 30 13 whatever it is
and so on and you then have to translate
them into the character codes you need
the advantage of that is if you've got
different localizations of the keyboard
so rather than having a UK keyboard
perhaps you've got a Swedish keyboard
like the one there away you've got keys
in different places so the qualities are
saying but you've got some of the
accented characters you've got less than
and greater than in a different location
well you've got a hash character or a
pound sign on the keyboard a dollar or
your own things that just just becomes a
software the actual keyboards are the
same you just got different key tops and
then the software says okay I'm going to
map this physical key to this character
code makes things easier so we're
got to what we've seen roughly how we
get to the hardware and then how we get
that as a signal into the computer in
which as we said we've got a serial line
whether it's over USB PS to a specialist
protocol Bluetooth whatever is SPI
however the keyboard is connected and
there's various different mechanisms
depending on what sort of computer
you're using or even just how you've
built it so you've got this message
coming through and that has to interrupt
the CPU to say hey this event has
happened in the real world you need to
handle this and so the CPU will stop
whatever it's doing whatever program is
running and say okay I've got to handle
this Hardware event because if it leaves
it too long while you might press
another key or something else might come
along like a network packet or a hard
disk data being transferred so it has to
handle it pretty much done in there at
that point you're crossing the divide
from the hardware side of things into
what's happening to the software
need to look at what the operating
system is going to do the device drivers
in there to pass this message that keys
been press open to the application or
the game that you're running whether
it's Microsoft Word quake or whatever it
is that you're doing
and I should caveat this by saying I'm
going we're talking in general terms
each operating system with us Windows
Linux Mac or iOS BSD insert your
favorite operating system here that you
probably